ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
esa es la pregunta y tú ya conoces al
amor de tu vida
sí
quién es
a ambos porque claro cuando te dicen
quién es el amor de tu vida siempre
contestarán yo bueno algunos contestarán
mis hijos otros contestarán mi papá a mi
mamá a otros en esta nueva época muy
millennial contestarán mi perro
es el amor de mi vida pero comúnmente y
sobre todo con tanta información ya
respondes yo gracias por el amor de tu
vida cuando conoces a alguien y te
enamoras profundamente esa persona que
haces para empezar a veces expansión
pelón y ahí vas tú dices hoy es tan
guapo mi bus
es lo más hermoso que he visto en mi
vida y por eso siguientes tres meses
ella es perfecta
no es perfecto es el más guapo es el más
precioso hasta que pasa en ese momento
de mariposas en la panza
y ya reconoces como que le duelen los
pies no
y ya de repente es como que dan china
está tan bonita
como que tiene pelito aquí
hoy ganó realmente contestaron muy bien
el amor de tu vida eres tú ahora la
pregunta es qué haces con este amor de
tu vida porque realmente después de
tantas historias ayer lo estaba
platicando la cenicienta mi hija y
entonces cuando ya venía el momento del
final claro que había algo dentro de mí
cuando ya se estaba acercando después de
la zapatilla de cristal después de todo
el tema el momento en el que ellos
quedan juntos algo en mí estuvo a punto
de decir y vivieron felices por siempre
y siempre lo hago siempre me freno
y le dije
y a veces fueron felices y a veces no y
lo intentaron mucho
esa es la realidad cuando compartes
románticamente con alguien porque
andamos en esta vida en la búsqueda sí o
no de ese the one
voy a hacer la música importante porque
cuando aparece de humana esto es la
música
a
[Música]
agravarán
tener enero
y entonces dices a huevo yo sí lo logré
se apareció me hizo ver la persona
perfecta y ahí vas en la vida hasta que
pasa el momento en el que ese
enamoramiento voy a volverlo a decir ese
enamoramiento
mientras
hasta entonces tenemos con esa persona y
entonces dices es que me mintió
me mintió y entonces ahora hablas mal
esa otra persona a quien amaba
profundamente
la ocasión
y así vas por la vida busqué y busqué y
busqué quién me va a ser feliz quién me
va a complementar quién me va a hablar
como yo quiero que me hablen quién me va
a amar como yo quiero ser amada
quién
yo
cabrón aquí estaba yo siempre
es que fíjense bien la noticia es que tú
no eres una naranja
y menos una mitad
como vas a encontrar a tu media naranja
eres un ser humano completo y desde la
completitud tienes tanto que dar y desde
ese ser entero tienes tanto que
compartir pero si no es reconocido eso
si no te has regalado ese momento decía
aquí estoy yo para ti
porque cuando yo me encuentro conmigo
qué hago por mí cuando yo realmente
conecto con esa energía y digo yo soy el
amor de mi vida que me voy a dar de
comer
como voy a hablar
como me voy a vestir como me voy a
apapachar como me estoy poniendo crema
porque sí o no a mujeres 1 se está
poniendo que la media de repente
empiezas una misión estuviera tan
celulítica de cada y si no me son este
gordito de aquí
en lugar de decir gracias nalguitas que
se sientan siempre bien suavecito y
gracias piernitas preciosas
chi chi estás en mi caso que le dieron
seis años de comer a mis hijos oigan
3 a cada uno
sí gracias muchas gracias gracias
chiquis que ahí siguen además arriba
todavía no me hace más o menos una
periodista
tanto que agradecemos tanto que cuidamos
cuando te descubres realmente como el
amor de tu vida tú te paras en frente
del espejo y te hablas cómo te gustaría
que te hablarán tú te das detalles
tú te pasas estás leyendo un libro y
pones un post-it 100 páginas adelante te
dices qué guapa y cuando llegas de esa
parte el libro porque claro cuando uno
es el amor de su vida invierte en su
educación y lee y lee y lee y se ama y
sepa pacha porque ese será el amor de tu
vida llegas esa página 100
veamos
aquí estoy yo para mí
hoy sí
qué bonito yo descubrí este en 2018 el
2018 pudo haber sido el peor año de mi
vida
como yo concebía la historia de mi vida
se derrumbó
[Música]
la familia hermosa en redes sociales y
que tu hermano felicitaban se cayó
mi dinero se ha invertido en un fondo de
inversión y la persona que lo manejaba
desapareció
tuve que llegar con mis hijos y decirles
que me iba a divorciar
con mis papás
estaba viviendo en tulum y decidí
regresar a méxico no sabía ni qué iba a
hacer cuando empezó 2019
y ese año 2018 porque soy una leona
soy león y es súper romántico que dije o
sea que no tengo nueve años casada con
el amor de mi vida
pues yo soy muy romántica entonces dije
quién será el amor de mi vida
y en ese momento
me detuve a punto de cumplir 40 años
y dije
y saben que este 2018 me dediqué a dar
conferencias de felicidad
por una u otra razón me invitaban a una
y otra y otra a hablar de felicidad a
hablar de amor a hablar de alimentar tu
vida y entonces al parejo que iba
corriendo esta historia que se caía iba
corriendo esta historia que se
reinventaba
y hay bombeo y ya claro porque aquí
estoy yo para mí y aquí están mis hijos
y ellos saben que mi felicidad no
depende de ellos y ese es mi mayor
regalo
que ellos sean felices me hace feliz a
mí
pero ellos pueden ser y hacer lo que
quieran
ese es el mayor regalo que sepan que
tienen una mamá
que tienen a un ser humano del cual
ellos dependen hoy que está completo que
sean que bailan las mañanas que se canta
en el espejo
en terrible pero me canto y me aceptó
así la loca que soy lo viva que estoy
entendiendo que la vida es un segundo y
que tú puedes decidir
irte al hoyo o levantarte a partir de
cualquier historia de tu vida porque te
tienes a ti y cuando estás en una
relación lo que yo aprendí es que cuando
estás pensando en que lo va a ser feliz
y que donde estás pensando que el otro
es hay tanta carga y tanta
responsabilidad de tanta mentira en eso
porque no es cierto nadie puede hacerte
feliz que las cosas terminan por morirse
que las cosas terminan por ya no fluir
creo que el verdadero romance es este no
te necesito no me haces falta puedo
vivir sin ti pero elijo vivir con
uff
si grado eso es amor chingado eso es
amor
de escuela conquista baila jazz y
negocia encoge porque cada quien negocia
lo que quiere en la vida pero hay que
negociarlo hay que hablarlo no supongas
porque a las mujeres se nos da mucho
suponer si él me va a ser fiel a mí
no todas no todas las desgracias y luego
los hombres también ya dicen más también
canicas ya lo que pasa aquí es no lo
cuentan
la libertad real el amarte realmente
tiene todo que ver con ser fiel el no
encontrarte contigo mismo el no amarte a
ti mismo tiene todo que ver con ser fiel
porque entonces cuando pasan esos meses
y pensabas que ella era la que te
llenaba
y después ya no te llena porque es sobre
una mentira va a seguir buscando a otra
que te llene y a otra que te llene y a
otra que te llene y se convierte en un
juego de nunca acabar
porque estás persiguiendo a zanahoria
que está ahí colgar y está pero que no
es verdad
si tú como hombre si tú como mujer que
volteas a ver a ti y te sabes como un
ser completo que va a pasar
que puedes aceptar compromisos de largo
alcance porque seamos honestos muchachos
ni que cogieran también
os la la neta porque si fueran campeones
en la cama una misma diría mi amor vell
enséñales
claro no diga mi amor comparte comparte
las mujeres y los hombres también son
buena onda pero no es cierto cuando tú
realmente quieres alcanzar ese estado
hermoso del que se habla con una persona
y al además andar repartiendo energía
con muchas otras
está muy complicado está muy complicado
que realmente puedas tocar el cielo con
esa persona y además andar jugando por
atrás me paso yo decía porque ya no
estoy tan enamorada porque esta energía
ya no estaba ahí esa energía estaba
repartida en muchos otros lugares y
estoy completamente en paz con eso
porque me trajo hoy aquí está que soy en
la mejor versión que yo he conocido de
claudia y eso sólo se puede agradecer
los maestros sólo se agradecen en la
vida y por supuesto que elegir de como
el amor de tu vida conlleva muchísima
responsabilidad porque tienes que
salirte de las relaciones tóxicas tienes
que dejar de lado el pero pero tú me
tenías que ser feliz
pero como sé tú y yo éramos o sean yo
dependo de ti
no tú dependes de ti
que tú estés bien depende sólo de ti
y entonces imagínate qué maravilla
encontrarte con una persona así del otro
lado
qué clase de relación fantástica
entonces si puedes construir con alguien
a partir de eso
todos locos enamorados de la vida
bailando con la vida siendo felices
celebrando la vida en absoluta confianza
porque sabes que estás con alguien
despierto
y entonces en esa persona puedes confiar
absolutamente y si hoy tienes una pareja
lo mejor que te puede pasar es ayudar a
que tu pareja se convierta en su mejor
versión entonces es si puedes mi amor
por supuesto y después de los 58 años 12
15 18 de casados verdad porque al
principio claro que tú puedes mejorar es
el mejor después no chingues otra vez
claro necesitas conectar con esa energía
con el otro y apoyarlo entusiasmarlo
pero no que lo tocara que depende de ti
ni de él para que se trabajo porque ese
trabajo te toca a ti porque ese trabajo
es tuyo y sólo tuyo porque esa es la
responsabilidad de hermosa de indy en el
libre albedrío de ahí viene ese que sí
es el amor absoluto one in four seven
24/7 completo y total de esa chispa
divina que esté nosotros
llámale como le quieran llamar yo le
digo dios yo tengo relación con el 200
humor como tú quieras llamarle está
perfecto padrísimo pero arranca te
porque ahí si hay un amor eterno desde
el cual tú puedes llenarte y compartir
con el mundo que cuando llegues digas
wikileaks obras muy esta persona dijo no
te digan quién te ama contesta es como
mi hijo y aunque por ahí anda mi amor
quien te ama yo
yo yo me amo yo estoy aquí para mí yo
estoy aquí para contar conmigo y sabes
que voy a hacer de esta experiencia en
este mundo algo único fantástico me voy
a llevar de viaje voy a ver el mejor de
los vinos
me voy a apapachar me voy a poner a
bailar conmigo me voy a poner a celebrar
la vida porque entiendo que es única que
es un regalo absoluto y que así como me
llamo hoy con esta experiencia de vida
con estos hijos que tengo con todo lo
que ha vivido y lo que me falta por
vivir es una y no se repite
a lo mejor regresas en otro quién sabe
para qué arriesgarme
si hoy estás aquí sí o puedes dar
abrazos de verdad si puedes saborear el
viento frío en tu cara cuando sufrió y
el sol ardiente cuando está de esa forma
si puedes celebrarlo todo porque dejarlo
para después de aquí estás tú para ti y
saben qué
eso hace que seamos libertad que seamos
verdad y que seamos alegría y ser es así
le urgen a este mundo a esta humanidad
entonces te conviertes en un regalo para
nosotros entonces tu vida es inspiración
a cada paso que das entonces puedes amar
de verdad
y ser humano
[Música]
[Aplausos]